Hi everyone! I hope you’re
all doing very well today.
My name is Olena. I’m a teacher of English
and I am very happy to be with you today.
Всім привіт! Сьогодні у нас з вами
буде урок англійської мови у 5-ому класі.
Мене звати Олена і я
вчитель англійської мови.
So, the topic of the lesson is: leisure.
Це – перше слово, яке
нам необхідно вивчити.
Що ж таке leisure? Leisure – це дозвілля.
Дозвілля, мабуть, найкращий час для всіх.
Оскільки, якщо ви подивитесь на цей знак.
What does it say? It says: no work.
Which means that we don’t have
any work to do and we can have rest.
Що означає цей знак? Що нам не потрібно
нічого робити, немає жодної роботи.
І leisure – це наше дозвілля.
Отже, the first job for you
today is to learn this word.
Перше, що ми сьогодні зробимо
– ми вивчимо саме це слово.
Найголовніше слово нашої теми.
If you learn the words just
repeating them million times,
of course its very effective.
But it’s quite boring.
Якщо ви вчите слова просто їх
повторюючи по мільйону разів –
звичайно, це дуже ефективно,
але це дуже-дуже нудно.
Отже, що ми можемо з вами зробити?
Я покажу вам, як це зробити,
і ви спробуєте разом зі мною.
Ми можемо говорити слово leisure різними
голосами. Просто спокійно: leisure.
А тепер уявімо, що ми дуже
суворий чоловік і ми скажемо: leisure!
And you can say it with me: leisure!
А тепер ми можемо зробити голос
маленької принцеси і сказати: leisure.
Very-very softly and nicely.
So, say it with me: leisure.
А тепер ми можемо
сказати leisure так голосно,
ніби ми звертаємося до когось,
хто стоїть на сусідній вулиці: leisure!
Дуже-дуже голосно
скажіть це разом зі мною.
Або, навпаки, ми хочемо сказати це пошепки
тому, хто сидить поруч із нами: leisure.
Okay, so I hope that you’ve
learned this word already
and we will use it many times today.
Be ready.
Сподіваюся, що ви вже вивчили це слово
і ми сьогодні будемо його ще
дуже багато разів використовувати.
Отже, як ще ми можемо
сказати слово leisure?
Бо одне слово не може просто існувати.
Нам потрібно обов’язково
його долучити до інших слів.
What can we say?
My leisure – моє дозвілля.
Your leisure – ваше дозвілля.
Our leisure – наше дозвілля.
Що ми ще можемо додати?
Ми можемо сказати: в час
мого дозвілля. Як ми це скажемо?
In my leisure time.
Бачите вже, як багато ми можемо сказати?
А якщо ви дуже розумні, ми можемо
додати ще, що ми любимо робити.
Ми можемо сказати: in my leisure time
I like painting the most. For example.
В час мого дозвілля я
дуже-дуже люблю малювати.
Як ще ми можемо замінити це слово?
Подивіться, будь ласка.
У нас є слово free time.
Що це означає? Вільний час. Вільний
від роботи час, від навчання час.
Або non-working time від слова work.
Non-working time означає: жодної роботи у
нас нема і ми можемо тільки відпочивати.
Spare time або break –
вільний час або перерва.
Nothing-to-do time – також зручний час,
коли нічого не потрібно нам
робити і це також дуже корисно.
An enjoyable activity time.
Тобто це той час, коли ми можемо займатися
тими справами,
які нам найбільше подобаються.
Okay. So, you can see those pictures and
these are just some examples of activities
that we might enjoy
doing in our spare time.
Зараз на дошці ви бачите
малюночки і слова, і фрази,
які нам обов’язково треба вивчити.
І це лише деякі приклади з того, чим
ми можемо займатися у наш вільний час.
Наприклад: can you see
this popcorn box? Yeah?
So, what does it mean?
That we can go to the cinema.
One of the activities is
going to the cinema or theatre.
Похід в кіно або театр. Having a picnic.
Can you see this nice
family having a picnic outside?
Ми можемо піти на пікнік. Cycling
– чудове заняття велоспортом.
Painting, by the way,
that`s what I love the most -
це, між іншим, те, що найбільше
подобається мені – живопис, малювання.
Listening to the music. I
guess everyone does that.
We cannot live without
music. Слухання музики.
Reading a book or piles
of books. Читання книжок.
Playing computer games.
I’m sure you love doing that.
Ігри, комп’ютерні ігри.
And playing football, tennis,
basketball, baseball and other games.
Гра у футбол, теніс,
баскетбол та інші ігри.
А також spending time with friends.
Це – чудово проводити час з
нашими друзями або з нашою сім’єю.
So, let’s read them
together one more time.
Я читаю і ви читаєте дуже-дуже
голосно разом зі мною.
Так, щоб всі у вашому домі
чули, як ви вчите англійську.
Отже, going to the cinema –
похід у кіно. Having a picnic – пікнік.
Cycling – їзда на велосипеді.
Painting – живопис.
Listening to the music – слухання музики.
Reading a book – читання книжок.
Playing computer games
– гра у комп’ютерні ігри.
Spending time with
friends – заняття з друзями.
Playing football, tennis, basketball
and a million other games –
гра в різні ігри, такі як:
футбол теніс і баскетбол.
Що би я радила вам зробити?
Для наших занять англійською
вам обов’язково треба
маленький записничок або зошит.
В який ви, якраз, зараз можете
записати слова з цієї теми,
які для вас будуть дуже-дуже корисними.
Ще би я радила вам ніколи
не вчити слова окремо,
а одразу починати думати про
те, як ми можемо їх використати.
Адже, якщо ви будете знати купу слів,
але не будете їх
використовувати – все це марно.
Отже, let’s think about going to
the cinema. I can go to the cinema.
I go to the cinema with my friends.
I go to the cinema every weekend.
I often go to the cinema.
Отже, ми можемо сказати, що:
"Я часто ходжу в кіно з друзями."
"Я дуже люблю ходити в кіно. Я роблю це
кожної суботи, кожні вихідні", наприклад.
Having a picnic. “It is very
nice to have a picnic outside."
"I love having picnics. We often
have picnics with my family”. Okay.
А що я хочу, щоб ми зробили зараз –
я вам запропоную дуже швидку
і ефективну гру на пам’ять.
Я буду вам показувати ось
такі листочки з написами.
Звичайно, тими фразами, які ми вже з
вами повторили і практикуємо. Їх буде 5.
Отже, перший раз я
покажу вам 5 таких фраз.
Наприклад: going to
the cinema, reading books,
cycling, swimming and
spending time with your family.
Їх буде 5. Наступного разу я покажу 4.
І ви повинні дуже-дуже
голосно мені сказати, якої бракує.
І наша активність називається
“What is missing”. Чого бракує?
Чого не вистачає? Це дуже-дуже
легка вправа, дуже легка гра.
Але, якраз, я хочу, щоб
ви брали в ній участь.
Отже, you have to be very-very careful.
You have to switch your eyes.
Switch your ears, listen to me
carefully and watch what I'm doing.
Отже, їх буде 5, давайте запам’ятовувати.
Playing computer games.
Painting.
Listening to the music – слухання
музики, нагадую вам. Далі.
Swimming – плавання.
And playing football.
Сподіваюся, що ви їх
запам’ятали. Тепер я їх перемішую.
І покажу вам лише 4. А ви
скажете мені, якої не вистачає.
Отже, the first one is painting – живопис.
The second one is swimming – плавання.
The third one is playing computer games.
And the last one is playing football.
Let us think now which one
is missing. То якої бракує?
Зараз ви дуже-дуже голосно повинні
мені сказати: listening to the music.
Ось цієї бракувало. Добре,
тепер я покажу вам лише 3 картки
і двох буде не вистачати.
І ви дуже голосно мені скажете,
яких саме. Отже, I'm mixing my cards.
Перемішую їх знову. And
I will show you those ones.
The first one is swimming.
The second one is painting
– малювання, живопис.
And the last one is
listening to the music.
Тільки три. Тепер подумайте,
яких двох нам бракує.
Абсолютно правильно – playing
football і playing computer games.
Добре, зараз я покажу
вам лише дві картки.
І ви мені скажете, яких трьох не вистачає.
Отже, перша буде у нас – painting.
Друга – playing football.
Тепер подумайте дуже-дуже добре і скажіть
мені правильну відповідь дуже голосно.
Playing computer games is missing.
Listening to the music is missing.
And swimming.
А тепер я виберу лише одну
картку. А чотирьох не буде вистачати.
Отже, картка, яку я вам показую
– це playing computer games.
Чи можете ви пригадати, які ще
у нас були заняття і яких бракує?
Давайте разом: playing
football, painting, swimming,
а також listening to the music. Дуже
добре, дуже вам дякую за вашу участь.
І я впевнена, що ми вже вивчили ці фрази.
Ще одна маленька штучка,
яка могла би вам допомогти.
Як ви можете вчити слова. Можливо,
вам краще малювати малюнки.
То в своєму зошиті ви можете зробити
словничок із вашими малюночками.
Де ви могли б малювати саме ваш
малюнок, який буде означати це слово.
Або також дуже fun way to do
that, to show, to mime the words.
Що означає – показувати.
Ви всі знаєте гру у крокодила.
Отже, ви можете попросити
своїх друзів, своїх однокласників,
своїх родичів, для того,
щоб вони вам допомогли.
Що ви можете робити?
Вам просто треба показувати ці слова і
хтось буде говорити відповідь або навпаки.
So, what am I showing right
now? That’s a very easy one.
That’s swimming.
Or what am I doing right now? You can
see I'm catching and throwing the ball.
I'm playing volleyball. Or what
I'm playing right now, like that?
That’s tennis.
Отже, це дуже-дуже ефективний,
дуже простий і веселий метод,
як ви можете собі
допомогти вивчити нові слова.
Добре, ідемо далі.
What does it say? Time to practice.
Ми вже вивчили слова і фрази,
і тепер час практикуватися.
Отже, я хочу, щоб ви трошки поговорили.
Окрім того, що ви вже вивчили ці фрази, це
чудово, ви їх запам’ятали, ви їх знаєте.
Але ми повинні навчитися, як
правильно будувати з ними речення.
It is very important to not just know
the words, not just learn the words.
But we have to use them in the context
and we have to use them in sentences.
Я спеціально для вас підібрала ось ці
малюночки сердечок для того, щоб показати,
як ми англійськими словами можемо
показати, що нам дуже подобається
або навпаки не дуже, або чого
ми зовсім не любимо робити.
Отже, для того, щоб сказати, що нам щось
подобається ми використовуємо два слова:
I like – що означає «мені подобається».
Ви бачите лише одне сердечко.
Далі ось цей хрестик означає те, що
взагалі мені не подобається щось робити -
I don’t like doing something.
Два сердечка означає,
що дуже мені подобається.
І тоді до фрази “I like” ми додаємо
“very much”, що означає «дуже».
Але, будь ласка, не потрібно говорити
“I like very much doing something”.
Це неправильно. В англійській
мові “very much” повинно бути в кінці.
Отже, ви говорите: I like playing
music very much, наприклад.
I enjoy – я насолоджуюся.
I enjoy painting. I enjoy
playing computer games.
I enjoy spending time with my family.
Далі – я люблю.
Це коли вже вам щось дуже-дуже-дуже
сильно подобається, ви любите щось робити.
I love spending time with
my family. I love going out.
I love playing tennis.
Далі – коли ви у захваті від чогось, ви
можете використати таку чудову фразу, як
“I’m fond of” або “I'm keen on”.
Це означає – я у захваті.
I'm fond of painting. I'm
keen on remodeling things.
I'm fond of decorating things.
Приклади можуть бути будь-які.
Ми пам’ятаємо, що
leisure is the matter of taste.
Наше дозвілля залежить
від наших вподобань.
Отже, тут приклади
могли би бути будь-які.
And the last one.
Коли ми хочемо сказати,
що щось нам подобається
більш-більш-більш за все, найбільш.
Що ми використовуємо? Два
слова: the most – більше всього.
Тобто ви говорите: I love або I
like щось робити більш за все.
I like playing computer games the most.
I like reading books the most.
Я сподіваюсь, що ви вже
це зрозуміли і вивчили.
І тепер ми трошечки попрактикуємося.
Отже, давайте напишемо: I like.
Я напишу вам свій варіант і я хочу,
щоб ви в своєму зошиті написали свій.
Час трошки пописати і
трошки подумати про те,
що нам подобається і
зробити свої власні речення.
Отже, ми пишемо: I like…
Ми пишемо: I don’t like…
Ми пишемо: I love, якщо ми
щось дуже сильно любимо робити.
Та: I love ___ the most
або I like ___ very much.
Отже, я зараз з вами поділюсь
тим, що я люблю робити.
Подивимось, що в нас є.
Отже, мій топ 10 – це painting.
Отже, я можу поставити його сюди.
Оскільки painting – це те, що
я люблю робити більш за все.
I say: I love painting the most.
Це означає, що більш за
все мені подобається живопис.
Що мені ще подобається? Давайте подумаємо.
So, I can use this word. What
does it mean? Swimming, you know.
Ви вже знаєте, що означає
swimming – плавання.
Отже, I like swimming very much –
мені дуже подобається плавання.
Але ми пам’ятаємо, що «дуже» в українській
мові ми говоримо на початку речення.
А в англійській мові воно
відправляється в кінець.
Отже, I like swimming very much. Давайте
подумаємо, що я не люблю робити?
Ну, скажімо, playing football.
Like any princess – I don’t
like playing football, sorry.
But I think that you do. Це моє.
Так, я не люблю грати в футбол.
І у мене залишається I like і I love –
що мені подобається і що я люблю.
Ну, скажімо, I like spending
time with my family and friends –
мені подобається проводити
час зі своїми друзями та сім’єю
і я люблю слухати музику.
Ось такі речення про мене.
Тепер я хочу, щоб ви добре подумали,
що ви любите, а чого ви не любите
і склали такі легкі речення
із вашими прикладами.
І, будь ласка, не відкладайте
далеко свій зошит і ручку,
оскільки наступне завдання у
нас також пов’язане з письмом.
Отже, now we are going to practice
writing. Трошки будемо писати.
Що ж ми будемо писати?
We have different activities.
You can see, we have reading, you
know it already. Читання ви вже вивчили.
Basketball – гра в баскетбол. Drama –
театр, гра. Poems – вірші. Tennis – теніс.
Choir – дуже складне слово, читайте
його правильно “choir” – це хор.
Volleyball – волейбол. Music – музика.
Karate – карате. Aerobics – аеробіка.
Drawing – малювання. Football –
футбол. Gymnastics – гімнастика.
Swimming – плавання.
Skating – катання на ковзанах.
And this very hard word - це дуже
складне слово означає «мова» - language.
Отже, що я хочу, щоб ви зробили?
I want you to split a
page into two halfs –
ви повинні поділити свій
зошиток на дві рівні частини.
І ви вже знаєте, що означають
фрази “I like” або “I don’t like” -
я люблю, мені подобається
або мені не подобається.
І тепер вам трошечки потрібно
подумати, і проаналізувати,
які речі вам до вподоби, а які - ні.
Отже, ви в першу
колоночку пишете “I like”
і вибираєте з цього переліку
все те, що вам подобається.
З іншого боку – ви пишете “I don’t like”
and you write those things
that you don’t like doing.
І з другої сторони, ті слова,
які не дуже вам подобаються.
Ті заняття, які вам не до вподоби.
А після цього ви можете
проаналізувати і подумати –
можливо ви чогось ще не спробували?
І, можливо, варто
спробувати якісь нові заняття.
Also, I want to draw your
attention to one thing –
також я хочу на одному наголосити.
Подивіться, будь ласка, на слова:
volleyball, football, gymnastics,
basketball, tennis, karate.
Вони означають те
саме, що і в українській,
і вони звучать так само,
як і українські слова.
Basketball – баскетбол.
Tennis – теніс. Football – футбол.
Тому їх дуже-дуже легко вивчити і ви
можете вважати, що ви вже їх знаєте.
Єдиний момент, на який я
мушу звернути вашу увагу –
це те, що треба звертати увагу і
бути уважним, коли ви пишете ці слова.
So, the only thing that you
have to learn is the spelling
and you have to mind the spelling
every time you use these words.
Добре, now its time for grammar.
Отже, я буду використовувати
двох маленьких помічників.
Ось цю чудову коробочку і
тенісний м’ячик, якраз в нашу тему.
Отже, я буду вам показувати
положення м’ячика відносно до коробочки
і таким чином ми будемо
вчити прийменники місця.
Англійською мовою вони
називаються “prepositions of place”.
I know that you probably know
already all those tiny little words
that tell us about the location
of the objects in space.
Ці малесенькі слова допомагають
нам відповідати на питання де?
І говорити про те, де
знаходяться предмети у просторі
та по відношенню один до одного.
Почнімо.
Отже, I will be asking the
question – буду задавати питання:
where is the ball – де наш м’ячик?
Here is the ball, here is the box.
Отже, якщо наш м’ячик ховається
в коробці – where is the ball?
The ball is in the box.
Where is the ball? Якщо він поряд.
The ball is next to the
box or close to the box.
Where is the ball right now?
You can see it over there.
It is called - in front of the box.
Where is the ball right
now? You can’t see it.
It is hiding. Зараз він
захований, він за коробочкою.
Як ми говоримо за? Behind.
Якщо він під коробкою –
it is under, under the box.
А якщо він знаходиться на коробочці,
ось таким чином – the ball is on the box.
Якщо він трошки вище – the ball is above.
Якщо він нижче – the ball is below.
So, we can put our helpers
aside for them to rest a little bit.
Відкладаємо наших помічників.
І дивимось на наші слова.
Давайте ще раз разом. Ви можете
повторювати їх разом зі мною.
In або inside означає «в».
І ви можете бачити маленький
малюночок, і коробочки, і м’ячика.
On – зверху, на.
Under – під. Behind – за.
In front of – попереду.
Above – над. Below – нижче.
Between - між.
І біля ми можемо сказати декількома
словами – next to, near або close to.
Opposite – напроти.
Отже, знову ж таки, ви берете свій зошиток
і берете всі ці слова з перекладом.
Або, якщо вам буде зручніше, ви
можете просто намалювати малюночки
і надписати зверху слова. Чудово.
І останнє на сьогодні
завдання – це буде drawing.
Буде малювання. Ви вже вивчили прийменники
місця і тепер нам просто необхідно
їх застосувати на практиці.
Ви ж пам’ятаєте, що ми не просто вчимо
слова окремо, а намагаємося зробити так,
щоб вони мали сенс в
реченнях і в тексті. Добре?
Отже, що ми зраза будемо робити?
I know that you all like drawing - я
думаю ви всі дуже любите малювати.
So, you need a piece of
paper and a pen or a pencil,
or you can draw in your
copybooks, in your notebooks.
Ви, знов ж таки, берете папірчик або
записничок, зошиток
і ми будемо з вами малювати.
Отже, я вам зараз буду говорити дуже
повільно про розміщення певних об’єктів.
Ви повинні мене уважно слухати і
малювати те, що я буду вам говорити.
Лише малювати. Okay.
So, there are three houses.
The first one is a swimming pool.
The second one is a library
and the third one is a shop.
Library is between the
shop and the swimming pool.
Behind the library there is a big tree.
In front of the library there is a car.
Next to the swimming
pool there is a bus stop.
Давайте ще раз але українською
і англійською я буду
говорити тільки прийменники.
Отже, уявімо таку вулицю, на
якій розташовано три будинки.
Перший з них – це басейн. Другий будинок
– це бібліотека. А третій – це магазин.
Бібліотека знаходиться
between басейном та магазином.
Ви вже знаєте, що таке between – між.
Behind the library – за бібліотекою
є велике дерево, яке також
ви можете намалювати.
In front of the library – перед
бібліотекою стоїть машина.
And next to the swimming
pool there is a bus stop –
а поряд із басейном є зупинка автобусу.
Отже, зараз ви подивитесь на
те, який малюнок підготувала вам я
і ви порівняєте свої малюнки із моїм.
Добре. Отже, що ви зробимо зараз?
Ми порівняємо ваші малюночки з моїм.
Я впевнена, що ваші виглядають
набагато краще, ніж мій,
бо я впевнена, що ви всі дуже
талановиті і любите малювати.
Але, все ж таки, зробила, що змогла.
So, let’s look at the picture.
And I will be reminding
you what I said before –
також я трошечки вам
нагадаю, про що я говорила.
Отже, у нас є три будинки.
Shop, library, where we can read books
and the swimming pool, where we can swim.
І що у нас знаходиться між, посерединці?
Library. Library – бібліотека -
знаходиться між магазином та між басейном.
Next to there is a bus stop.
Поряд із басейном є зупинка транспорту.
And what about this beautiful tree?
It is behind the library.
Де знаходиться дерево? За бібліотекою.
А що ж з приводу цієї машинки?
Вона знаходиться in front of
the library. Де вона знаходиться?
Попереду. Перед бібліотекою. Ось
така у нас була вправа на малювання.
На цьому ми закінчуємо з
граматикою і ми закінчуємо наш урок.
I heard the bell ringing. Я
вже чула, як лунає дзвіночок.
So, it’s time to finish.
It was a great pleasure for
me to be here with you today –
я з великою радістю сьогодні була з вами.
Бажаю вам успіхів, прекрасного
чудового дня. До побачення!